fine
[Music]
so we saved some of the best for the
last
so we have a sequence of two talks
uh
by aaron roth from upend
and
after aaron vasilis
for microsoft research so
uh it's a pleasure to have aaron with us
so
i'll take it away
all right so thanks for having me
so i want to talk about
sort of a very simple
framework
that makes it easy to derive
all sorts of online learning algorithms
um
that i think is cool so i let me tell
you about it so this is joint work with
um
an undergraduate at penn daniel lee and
the pt student george norov and uh
and so i want to start with
two motivating
problems just sort of two cool examples
of online adversarial problems but these
are sort of two examples of what are you
know many things that you can derive in
this framework
but let me you know like walk you
through two of them so that you have
something concrete to hold on to
and the first is about predicting um
with sort of meaningful estimates of
uncertainty
so
think about what do or what should
reported uncertainty estimates mean
and imagine that
um
maybe there was a pandemic recently and
it's just starting
um
it's moving through a population and
so it's an online problem where things
are rapidly changing like maybe the
population of people affected is
changing over time
the the
treatments are changing over time
and we need to make some kind of
prediction as people come in like given
your features x that i can read off of
your medical chart
um what's your expected disease severity
in two days time so maybe we've got some
model for doing this and then the doctor
says okay well
given your features x
we think your expected disease severity
is f x
and so our patients might ask well
you know how sure are you of this
prediction
and
the doctor could say well i've got a 95
prediction interval that your disease
severity will be between you know some
lower bound l of x and some upper bound
u of x
and so if the doctor says that to the
patient
you know what does that mean
and so
um you know the patient might ask you
know is this really a prediction about
me personally like you know you're
stating this probabilistic guarantee is
it a statement
about what will happen to me 95 of the
time i guess over the
you know unrealized randomness of the
world
and if pressed the doctor will have to
say no that's that's not what it means
that would be impossible to so that
would be an impossible prediction to
make
um what i mean is that this is a 95
marginal prediction interval which means
it's an average over people what it
means is that
for 95 of people
uh for whom i you know with whom i have
this conversation
um the interval i give covers their
label and for five percent of people it
doesn't
and
our patient might feel that this is
unsatisfactory for example if she is
part of a demographic group representing
less than five percent of the population
because consistent with the promise of a
95 prediction interval if it's a
marginal prediction interval
is the possibility that it is always
wrong for her and for people like her
it's just an average over this like
large heterogeneous population
there might be medically relevant
demographic groups in this population
that are just like not captured in this
model at all so maybe it's like more
accurate for some people and less
accurate for others
and so she could say well what about for
people like me and maybe
you know maybe different studies have
been run and so the doctor could you
know look up some medical studies and
say well okay for african americans
under the age of 50 the 95 prediction
intervals from a to b
and for women with a family history of
diabetes the 95
prediction interval is from c to d and
for people with egg allergies and no
history of smoking the 95 prediction
intervals from e to f
and
note that these are not disjoint groups
so it could be that you know our patient
is a member of all of these groups
and consistent with the guarantees of a
95 marginal prediction interval might be
that for example a to b is entirely
disjoint from e to f
so it's not at all clear how to um
interpret
things like this
okay so that was
okay marginal guarantees for prediction
intervals uh perhaps you've heard of
calibration which is a marginal
guarantee for estimating the mean
all right so
suppose
you know i'm a weather forecaster and i
make confident assertions like
tomorrow there's a 30 chance of rain
well like what does that mean tomorrow
only happens once
and it's impossible to really check
whether i was right about tomorrow in
isolation or not and so calibration is
sort of this simple sanity check um that
marginalizes over days it says well um
if i average over all of the days for
which you predicted a 30 chance of rain
then it should average out too it should
in the long run have rained about 30 of
the time similarly if i average over all
of the days for which you predict a 70
chance of rain
and maybe that's fine for weather but
again
if the promise is just you know like for
30 of people for whom i predict they
will need an icu in three days time um
you know 30 of them really do
that is unsatisfying for the same reason
that these marginal prediction intervals
were unsatisfying because it's averaging
over what might be a very heterogeneous
population that have medically relevant
properties
and so hebrew johnson kim rheingold and
rothbloom proposed back in 2018 in a
very nice paper
a really nice
partial mitigation to this problem
called multi-calibration they talked
about it in the batch setting i'm going
to give you the definition for the
online setting that we worked out in
itcs but
you know like the
sort of sort of the same thing
and the idea
is
very simple and then natural in
hindsight it says
well
suppose i've got
demographic groups g these are just
subsets of the population so now like
imagine people have features they they
walk into my hospital
they present with features x
and
um
well they're a member of some of these
groups and not others the groups are
just subsets of the feature space okay
these can be intersecting groups so i
might be a member of five of these
groups
and
what multi-calibration asks for is that
um the sequence of predictions should be
calibrated not just overall right so
when i say
you know 30 so when i average over all
of the days in which i say 30 the
average of the label should also be 30
this should be the case not just overall
but also when i zoom in on each of the
subsequences that correspond to days in
which someone from each demographic
group walked in
okay so the nice thing is you know
you're making only one prediction per
person right like you know you say
well you know for you there's a there's
a 20
chance of whatever event i'm predicting
and i might be a member of a bunch of
these groups i might be
you know jewish a professor a resident
of pennsylvania
and i can interpret at my option uh this
prediction that's been made as an
average over any of those groups and and
and that average is correct
okay so that's a nice idea
and uh when you when you see that idea
you can generalize it to all sorts of
other um
kinds of predictions not just predicting
means so for example i could say well i
didn't like the marginal property of
these prediction intervals
maybe
what i'd be happier with if i had some
large collection of intersecting
demographic groups is what we call
prediction interval multi-validity it's
the natural extension of
multi-calibration to prediction
intervals
and it says
a sequence of prediction intervals
is multi-valid
if
when i look at
my empirical coverage probability well
of course overall
it should be 95
but it should also be 95 when i zoom in
on each of these different demographic
subgroups when i zoom in on the
subsequence of days on which the person
who showed up was in one of these
different demographic subgroups okay and
then this is you know we want this to be
the case even when the groups can be
intersecting so again this sort of
solves the interpretation problem i
might be a member of
ten of these 10 of these groups but
you've only predicted a single
prediction interval for me
and i can interpret this as a marginal
prediction interval over any of the
groups i am a member of and the
interpretation is simultaneously correct
for all of them
okay so this is some problem i think
it's an interesting problem
here's another problem this was one
studied by
um blum and licorice a couple of years
ago
that i'll call multi-group optimal
assignment
okay so imagine
i've got a sequence of people who are
coming in and i need to assign them to a
judge who's going to make some impactful
decision about them
okay so you know i've got this line of
people
the first one
walks in i say okay you're assigned to
the first judge
and the second one walks in i say you're
assigned to the second judge
okay
so in more detail we've got individuals
again who have features
and they arrive in sequence and we've
got a collection of groups
okay an individual can be a member of
more than one of these groups and these
groups can be arbitrarily intersecting
well
as they arrive we need to
make assignments of these individuals to
judges okay experts if you like
who are going to make some impactful
prediction maybe they're going to
predict the label so the j judge will
predict a label for the teeth individual
y hat jt
and then
you know after we do this we'll learn
what the individual's true label was and
each judge will have made a mistake or
not now there's a bunch of judges and
the judges might have different error
rates on these different demographic
groups maybe some of the judges are
better at making decisions for some
groups than others
and so we can talk about the error rate
of a judge on a particular demographic
group it is just the
number of mistakes that that judge would
have made on people um
from that demographic group had you
assigned all of the people from that
demographic group to judge
jay okay and the goal here
is to assign people to judges so that up
to diminishing regret terms
if i look at the average error
on each group g
it would be as low as if we had assigned
everyone from that group g to the judge
who in hindsight had the lowest error
for that group
okay so it's a no regret currency it
says we want to have no regret on each
of these groups
but but again it's sort of strengthening
sort of a standard no regret guarantee
which is a marginal guarantee to one
that's group wise so not only do i want
to have no regret
on the whole sequence but when i zoom in
on the subsequence corresponding to
people who of course you know who are
members of some group g
i want to have no regret on that
subsequence to the best uh judge for
that group so on different subsequences
the best judge is different
and again this is
you know the reason why you can't just
do something totally trivial like
running multiplicative a separate copy
of multiplicative weights say
for each demographic group is that these
groups are intersecting they're not
disjoint so i might be a member of five
different groups and yet like
nevertheless
when i you know i want that people in
pennsylvania should be
you know should should have prediction
error as low as the
judge as if they had all been assigned
to the judge that is best for people
from pennsylvania but like also i want
professors to have error that is
as low as
if all judges had been assigned to um
you know the sorry if all professors had
been assigned to the judge who had the
lowest error rate on professors and so
on okay so it's taking a marginal
guarantee like regret and sort of asking
for this finer grained group-wise thing
just as multi-calibration is asking for
this finer grand guarantee with a with a
calibration visitorada
and these are just two problems there's
like lots of problems you can derive and
the solutions to lots of problems you
can derive in the framework i'm going to
tell you about
so for example
just about any
notion of regret for a finite expert
problem you've ever heard of external
regret internal regret adaptive regret
sleeping expert subsequence regret um
there's more whose names are escaping me
basically i haven't encountered one that
doesn't fall out of this framework
um
calibration problem so i'll tell you
about mean calibration but we wrote a
paper about calibration for variance we
have
you know these prediction interval
multi-validity results they all fall out
of this framework you can get a variant
of of blackwell approachability from
this from this framework for polytopes
that has a fast convergence rate
and other stuff so i'm not going to
remind you what all of these things are
but i'm just going to tell you the
framework and then give you some idea of
how you can derive results for the for
the problems i've told you about
okay so
what is this framework i don't know by
the way if there's any
way in this um
presentation format for anyone to like
ask me questions but if there is feel
free to interrupt and ask me questions
to the best of your ability
um okay so what is this
general framework it's this
quite simple um
problem that we call
online minimax multi-objective
optimization
so here's the idea
play proceeds in rounds
and
at every round
an adversary proposes a potentially
totally new environment so the
environment you are playing in each
round could be totally different they
don't have to be related to one another
but what's an environment
well an environment consists of some
convex compact action set for the
learner and some convex compact action
set for the adversary
and a vector-valued loss function that
takes as input
an action for the learner and an action
for the adversary
and spits out a vector a d-dimensional
vector of losses
and what we require is that if i look at
each
coordinate of this loss function in
isolation that coordinate should be
convex in its first argument and concave
in its second
okay so the adversary
says
you know surprise you know here's the
game we're playing today it could be
different every day
and then
after the learner sees the game the
learner selects an action
and then
the adversary gets to look at the action
the learner selected and select
an action themselves in response
and this results in some d-dimensional
loss vector
now these loss vectors accumulate over
time
and what the learner wants to do is the
learner wants to minimize the maximum
coordinates in this accumulated loss
vector
okay so there's there's these d losses
the learner cares about making the
maximum of these d losses as they
accumulate over time
small
okay
so this is the last day in a in a week
of uh adversarial machine learning so i
don't have to remind anyone here what a
zero some game is but let me do it
anyway
so
a zero-sum game is defined by a
minimization player who we will always
associate with the learner
and the minimization player has some
convex compact strategy space and
there's also a maximization player
that will always identify with the
adversary here who also has a convex
compact strategy space
and then we have a utility function that
is one dimensional takes as input an
action for the learner an action key
adversary and spits out a a real number
and it's got to be convex in its first
coordinate and concave in its second
and like the cool you know like the one
thing to know about zero sum games is
the mini max theorem which just says the
order of play doesn't matter
okay so if the minimization player
has to
go first and announce their strategy and
then the maximization player has the
advantage of getting to best respond to
that with knowledge of the minimization
player's strategy
or if
in reverse the maximization player is
forced to go first and commit to an
action and the minimization player has
the advantage of getting to know their
opponent's action and best respond to
minimize
at least if everyone's playing the game
well the outcome is the same that's what
the mini max theorem says order of play
doesn't matter
okay
so
you know like
we're playing some zero-sum game we've
got the thing we want to minimize is
like the maximum coordinates of this
loss function um you might think well
maybe we can just define a zero-sum game
where the uh the payoff the per round
payoff is just the maximum coordinate of
this loss function and maybe that works
because
you know we did assume that every
coordinate of this loss function was
convex concave
um but that doesn't work right the max
does not preserve concavity for the
adversary and it's not just like a
technicality like it really doesn't so
just to like build some intuition
consider the following very simple game
where the strategy space for the
minimization player and for the
maximization player is just like the
polytope in d dimensions so they both
play some probability distribution over
d things
and the vector-valued payoff function
just in each of the d coordinates
is the difference between the
probability
that the maximization player puts on
coordinate i
and the probability that the
minimization player puts on coordinate i
so it's just linear in each coordinate
so it's definitely convex concave
but note like if we care about the
maximum of these coordinates
then if the maximization player is
forced to go first and reveal his
probability distribution the
minimization player can just match it
and make sure that the entry in every
coordinate is zero so the max is zero so
if max goes first min can obtain payoff
zero which is pretty good
on the other hand if min is forced to go
first and reveal uh her probability
distribution
then max can just look at it and say
well there's
one coordinate on which min put weight
at most one over d
max can put all of his weight there and
guarantee payoff one minus one over d
and here here the payoffs are kind of
like bounded by one so this is sort of
like the worst gap possible between you
know the value of the game if min goes
first and the value of the game if max
goes first so these really are different
okay so this is all to say
in these stage games
uh the mini max theorem doesn't hold so
there are two values for the game
there's the value of the game when the
learner moves first let's call that the
learner moves first value
okay that's just the
min max value so it's we're minimizing
over actions of the learner maximizing
over actions of the adversary and then
we're taking the maximum over
coordinates of this vector-valued loss
function
and then alternatively there's the
adversary moves first value of the game
when the adversary is forced to move
first it is a disadvantage to go first
and so we know that the
learner moves first value of the game is
bigger than the adversary moves first
value and as we saw in an example it can
be strictly bigger by a lot
okay
now of course
in reality the learner moves first
because we have to commit to a learning
algorithm and then we want to prove that
it does something good against all
possible adversaries and so um you know
in particular like the adversary might
be best responding to the choice of
action of the learner every round
so we can't achieve in the stage game
the adversary moves first value but what
we can still do is we can achieve
diminishing regret to the adversary
moves first value even though the
learner moves first
okay so we can't promise that in the
stage game but what we can promise is
that
um
if we look at the maximum coordinate of
the
accumulated loss functions
that you know the average of the max the
average of the maximum coordinate of the
accumulated loss functions
this should be at most the average of
the adversary moves first values of the
game
over time
these are different every round because
the game could be totally different at
each round maybe plus some regret term
that tends to zero okay like this is
it's possible we can do this right
because
um uh we get to average over time
so aaron
yes
so
it is you know you're taking the max of
the average here right
now that's right
and and so
somehow if you're taking the average of
the max then
that would be impossible that would be
impossible by the last slide
exactly right so the reason this is not
impossible is because it's the max of
the average rather than the average of
the max
yeah okay so um
is there actually intuition why uh the
max of the average this value that
you're
like obviously you're going to show that
you do pretty well here but uh is there
but like why is this situation a
reasonable
like are you asking why is this a
reasonable benchmark or yeah like uh
why why would it be that bad
yes
um it seems like yeah max of the average
is very different than the average
it is yeah and in particular the max of
the average um
you know we can like achieve this
balance and and if we wanted the average
of the max would be impossible
i think like a priori like if you're
just staring at this bound there's no
particular reason to think
you know like from first principles
maybe that this is the right benchmark
like you might think maybe we can do
better than this
i think
um the proof is sort of in the pudding
in that you can take this bound and then
derive all of those other bounds
bounds for all of those other problems
that sort of i listed on the slide so
this turns out to sort of be the right
thing and in particular right like like
one very simple thing you can derive
from bounds like this is just the
optimal you can drive multiple
multiplicative weights algorithm which
is sort of the
um the
retrieves the optimal bound for the very
simple external regret problem and we
know that that is optimal right for many
of the things we can derive actually
like we know that the bounds are optimal
which sort of means you cannot improve
on the generic bound
so i
um
i don't want to claim that it should be
obvious that like from staring at this
the deriving this is somehow interesting
or the right thing but what i claim is
that okay this is something you can
derive and then from this you can turn
the crank and derive regret bounds for a
whole bunch of other problems that turn
out to be optimal
oh
thanks yeah
okay
so let me tell you briefly like how you
derive it which is you know like if
you've
worked a lot in in regret learning like
nothing here is going to be surprising
like we're using reasonably
straightforward techniques
um
okay so we're gonna we're gonna move to
a surrogate loss function
so remember
we care about the adversary moves first
regret
and let's define the adversary moves
first regret
coordinate wise so we'll define the
adversary moves first regret for the jth
coordinate of our loss function
and this is just the sum over all of the
time steps of the difference between the
value accumulating in the js coordinates
of our loss function and the adversary
moves first value of the game
and then the adversary moves first
regret is just the maximum over all of
these coordinate wise regret functions
that right it's it's this maximum that's
causing us trouble it's the maximum that
makes the game not convex concave
okay so a natural thing to do and what
we do is to swap out this max for a soft
max so our surrogate loss function will
be this will rather than being the max
of all of these coordinate wise regret
terms it's just the the sum of the
weighted exponential of these coordinate
wise regret terms and the soft max is a
very nice surrogate loss function and
it's upper bound we can upper bound the
adversary moves first regret this thing
we really care about by the log of our
surrogate loss divided by
eta our learning rate
okay
another
reasonably straightforward thing to
derive about the surrogate loss function
is that it telescopes
by which i mean the following thing
if i look at
my surrogate loss today
i can upper bound that by some multiple
of my surrogate loss yesterday
plus a weighted sum over
all of the coordinates of my loss
function
of the
increase in
adversary moves first regret in that
coordinate in isolation somehow weighted
by the total adversary moves first
regrets i've accumulated in that
coordinate so far weighted by the
exponential
okay so
you know my my loss
today or after today
will be upper bounded by you know my
loss yesterday
plus
something that sort of looks like the
sum over all of the coordinates of the
loss function of my sort of per round
increase
in
surrogate loss in that coordinate that's
weighted by something that depends on
how well i've done in each coordinate so
far
and so a natural idea is to say well
okay you know i want to make sure that
the loss doesn't increase too quickly
because in the end my surrogate loss is
going to upper bound my real loss
and the increase is really controlled by
this sum here
the second term
and so maybe i'll define a surrogate
game
that i'm gonna
play in a zero-sum game that is just
equal where the utility function is just
equal to the sort of second term here
the term that's going to bounce my
increase in surrogate loss
and note that
in this surrogate game what we have is a
weighted sum of loss functions that are
each convex concave rather than a
maximum
and so like sums are nice so a sum of
convex concave loss functions is itself
convex concave and so so this surrogate
game is convex concave and the um you
know the minimax theorem applies
okay so this is our surrogate game
and note that it's very easy to derive
that the value of this surrogate game is
zero because the min max theorem applies
so when we're analyzing the value of the
surrogate game we can pretend that the
adversary moves first because the min
max theorem says the value of the game
is the same whether the adversary or the
or the learner move first
and
well if the adversary moves first
then
by definition we can achieve the
adversary moves first value of the game
right that was the definition of the
adversary moves first value of the game
and so we can guarantee that in every
coordinate our loss is less than the
adversary moves first value of the game
and so the value of the surrogate game
cannot be more than zero
okay
uh right so we're taking advantage of
the fact that we've moved to a convex
concave game so that we can swap them in
the max and achieve the adversary moves
first value of the game
okay
and then the algorithm is easy right the
algorithm is just write down the
surrogate game every round
play the min max equilibrium strategy of
this game that guarantees that
the value of that game is zero so that
guarantees that when we're keeping track
of the increase in surrogate loss over
time this term is entirely zeroed out
okay and so the increase is very small
and you can from that relatively
directly derive our final bound for the
general framework which is that
when i look at the
maximum coordinate of the accumulated
loss vector
uh
you know it's it's at most the average
of the adversary moves first values of
the games we've encountered plus uh you
know optimal square root log d over t
regret term
so aaron
so you're saying that your
your surrogate game at
each time step
the the environment sort of surrogate
environment this game is
is
zero sum
um
this
like
that's right like in the in the actual
interaction there's this like d
dimensional loss vector but this
surrogate game here this is a zero-sum
game uh with a maximization player and a
minimum you know who's the adversary and
a minimization player that's you the
learner
and so so
how does this uh
how does it correspond to you you also
want this uh
i i believe you it's just confusing that
this also then is a good approximation
to
the game that you actually wanted
to play
well the the connection is that
the game that i actually want to play
has regret that is upper bounded by
the surrogate loss
and the
zero that is over the entire sequence of
time steps right that's that's right
okay and the stage game that upper
bounds the increase in surrogate loss
per round
does that make sense
yeah
thank you
cool
okay so you get this regret bound
okay so let's turn the crank a few times
so from this let's get um let's get
multi-calibration
so we need to define an action space for
the learner in the adversary now
remember
in this framework we need the
loss function every coordinate to be
like convex concave and for some loss
you know for some things like
multi-calibration when you write down
the obvious loss function it's not
convex say in the
action in the actions available to the
learner but there's like a
simple trick to solve this problem which
is just to discretize the actions of the
learner and define the learner's action
space to be
distributions probability distributions
over this
finite
set of pure strategies which convexifies
the problem so we're doing that here
there's some discretization parameter uh
controlling the
how fine-grained the um learner's action
space is and we're going to allow the
learner to randomize
and then we'll say okay we've got to
define a d-dimensional loss function
that so that's going to be related you
know if we can if we can
minimize the maximum coordinate will
mean that we're multi calibrated
so we'll just say okay we'll have a loss
function that's going to have a
coordinate for each group and for each
discrete prediction we can make
and for each direction plus one or minus
one in which our prediction might be
you know either too big or too small
okay and if i predict p
and the true label is y
then in this coordinate of the loss
function well
it'll just be zero if the person who
showed up today wasn't in that group
doesn't contribute to loss for that
group
it'll also just be zero if i didn't
predict p doesn't contribute to the
calibration loss associated with
predicting p
and then it'll be either
uh
you know my prediction minus the label
or the label minus my prediction
depending on whether this sign is
positive or negative
and note that if i can
upper bound the maximum accumulated
value of each of these coordinates that
will mean that i'm multi-calibrated
so we have to to apply this framework
upper bound the adversary moves first
value of the game which is pretty easy
right if the adversary moved first and
told me a distribution over labels
then what i would want to do to zero out
every coordinate
is predict
uh the mean
of that label distribution
that would zero out all of these
coordinates it would mean the adversary
moves first value is zero
well i i can't do that because
um you know like the adversary could
play could have a player distribution
for which the mean was any real value
and my action space as the learner is
discretized at multiples of one over r
but i can always play the closest
multiple so that means the adversary
moves first value of the game at each
round is one over r
okay because i can match the label
distribution the mean of the label
distribution up to the discretization
error
and then i can just apply the general
theorem and and
find that my multi-calibration error is
at most well one over r that's the
adversary moves first value of the game
plus the regret term which is just
logarithmic in the number of coordinates
and how many coordinates are there well
just
um you know one for each discrete
prediction i could make one for each uh
group and and one for each sign it's
just the log of all of that
okay and i can make r like i choose r
right so i can make r like a low order
term if i want it it shows up only in
the log
and just to like mention that this is
not merely like an existential result
right
there's an easy way to turn the crank
and to get the algorithm and you can do
that in this case and get quite an
efficient algorithm
you just have to
the algorithm is always play the min max
strategy of the surrogate game and
oftentimes when you when you just think
about that you can get it in closed form
and always you can get it by solving a
linear program that has a number of
variables equal to the
number of strategies available to the
learner
and a number of constraints equal to the
uh dimension of the game
so i won't go through the algorithm just
to note that for everything you derive
in this way you can turn the crank solve
an equilibrium computation problem and
get an algorithm
okay how about this multi-group optimal
assignment
well
can i ask one more question yes
uh
going
back a slide what what is your
calibration loss here
you're so
right p you're you're thinking of as uh
like
uh in the simplex or actually uh
so here p is one of the discrete uh okay
predictions and i'm i'm glossing over
the issue of bucketing which is great
yeah you understand but it's difficult
to
talk okay great yes
thanks
uh yes okay
so i've got a couple minutes left so
let's drive some more stuff
how about
multi-group optimal assignment
well
again i'm just going to define a loss
function that has a dimension uh for
each group
and for each judge
and well like my action space as the
learner in this problem is to choose a
judge
and the adversary's action space is to
choose a label for the person who showed
up as well as a prediction for all of
these judges
which establishes um if they choose a
distribution over such things in error
rates an error probability for each of
the judges
and so my loss for each group
and for each judge j prime well it's
just zero if the person who showed up
today was not in that group uh otherwise
it is just
sort of my per round regret right i
chose action j
uh i chose judge jay
you know what is my regret to judge j
prime well it's just the indicator of
whether judge j the one i chose made a
mistake today
minus the indicator of whether judge j
prime made a mistake i have regret to
judge j prime if my judge made a mistake
and the other guy didn't
and again if i
can bound the accumulated you know if i
can bound the accumulated loss for each
of these coordinates that will mean that
when i look at the regret for each group
to the best judge in that group it'll be
small
okay and here the adversary moves first
value is zero
right the reason is
once the adversary commits to a
distribution over labels and predictions
for the judges that gives us sort of an
expected error rate for each of the
judges on this individual and if the
adversary told us ahead of time what the
error rate was free to judge i would
just assign the judge
i would just assign today's individual
to the judge that um
to the judge that
had the lowest error rate that would
sort of make all of these coordinates
non-positive
and so again we can invoke the generic
bounds and find that simultaneously for
every group g
if i look at the
average error rate for people in that
group it is at most the average error
rate for
the you know made by the best judge for
people in that group up to this regret
term that
scales with log of the number of judges
times the number of groups
and once again you can turn the crank
and derive from this automatically an
efficient algorithm for doing this
okay and then here's like a neat thing
um you can combine multiple constraints
so say i want both multi-group regret
and calibration
and say that i wasn't
using the zero one loss function but i
was using a proper
scoring rule as a loss function
something like squared error or log loss
then
fixing the adversary's distribution over
labels the prediction that minimizes
loss is just the expected value of the
label distribution and so also satisfies
calibration constraints
which means that if i have regret if i
want regret constraints that are
measured with respect to some proper
scoring rule this is compatible with
calibration constraints and so you can
get
cal a beating which is a word that
foster and heart came up with in a paper
uh they put online last year so
here's a picture
again you've got these you know people
showing up and now you've got a bunch of
different arbitrary models who are each
making predictions about the labels that
these people will have
you the algorithm sitting down here look
at these labels then you get to make
your own prediction
okay
and the goal is that um
you know every day right so the model is
you've got these m models
every day someone shows up the models
produce predictions you somehow combine
those and produce your own prediction
and then learn the label
and the goal is not only should your
predictions be multi-calibrated but they
should have lower squared error or lower
error according to whatever proper
scoring rule you care about uh compared
to any of these models and in fact they
ask for not just lower squared error but
strictly lower squared error to the
extents that
the models you're improving on are not
already calibrated
and you can immediately
get that result here as well except with
a better dependence on the number of
models by just combining the sort of
coordinates that we put in our
you know min max framework that come
from the multi-group regret constraints
together with the coordinates that come
with the calibration constraints and
noting that because the scoring rule is
proper
you can simultaneously
you know make all of these small when
the adversary moves first right if you
predict the the mean of the label
distribution you zero out the regret
constraints as well as the calibration
constraints
and so what you can get
is that
when i look at for any group
uh the squared error of our predictions
on that group
it is
at most the squared error of the best
model on that group
uh in fact even better than that you
know better by the calibration error of
that model uh plus a regret term that
scales with the number of models and uh
um
the number of groups and also
simultaneously your predictions are
multi-calibrated
okay so i'm out of time so let me just
point out that you can turn this crank
more times to derive a bunch of other
stuff
if you like you know regret algorithms
none of this stuff is not like
new right like we're re-deriving
bounds that are that are already known
but typically we get optimal bounds and
efficient algorithms and the nice thing
is that they all come from turning the
crank on this on the same
little framework here
so
uh thank you there's two papers the the
general framework is in
um
this paper that's not quite online
there's an older version of it online
but it's going to be called online mini
max multi-objective optimization
multi-calibeating and other applications
and
the
paper where we derive the online
algorithms for um prediction interval
multi-validity that was in itcs this
year so thank you
thank you aaron for the very interesting
talk um
uh so there's a one question in the chat
uh i'm not sure if it's
referring to um
mathematical
is mathematical or
in practice question but the question is
how do you compute the mistake or error
made by judge
roughly in a general sense
yeah so let's see so i mean in general
you'd have some arbitrary loss function
but like in the slides i was just
talking about zero one loss so so
someone shows up
um the judge gives the prediction
y hat
then you learn the true label of the
person why and you say that they've made
a mistake if y hat is not equal to y
okay so that's the answer in the
mathematical model if you're asking
about
actually applying this to like
judges um
you know
it
uh delayed the response
presumably
that's right so um
so in the in the model in which we work
things out
uh you get the response right away after
um or rather you get the response before
you need to make the next prediction
now
in general you know like i guess you can
always get
a response that is sort of delayed by
our rounds and and have some term that
you know some extra determine your
regret that grows and somehow in
proportion to r
um
i don't know of this wasn't something we
were thinking of and so i don't know a
general method for
i don't have a method for dealing with a
delayed response here that
is better than any other method for
dealing with delayed response it's just
not something we're thinking about here
hey aaron thanks for a great talk um
one quick question so uh this idea of
calibrating is new to me um have you
thought at all
about how that relates to this work on
omni predictions
um
let's see
so it's
it's not really new to you because you
do something very similar in the batch
setting in your literacy calibration
paper
um
the only difference is okay i don't
think foster and heart had read your
paper but
they asked for it in
the online setting and then
there's this there's this notion of like
how much you're supposed to improve on
the
predictors you're beating
and
in your paper you have
an improvement that
depends somehow on like how much you've
like changed the
predictor you started with
like how it
somehow depends on how much the
multi-calibration updates change the
original predictor
and uh foster and heart define
multi-calibeating with what i think is
sort of a cleaner measure which is that
you can talk about the you can decompose
say the squared error of the original
predictors into a calibration error
component
and
the rest of it
and
they ask for beating
when i'm evaluating how well we do on
squared error it's supposed to be better
than
each of the predictors by exactly their
calibration error
so that's another um
difference
uh but but otherwise it's i think it's
sort of more it's like the on morally up
to this you know technical difference in
what's being asked for it's like the
online version of your no harm property
cool
thanks
all right well thank you
very much
thank you very much
[Applause]
you